this is a production of Cornell
University
thank you drift I really think everyone
can hear me alright I think I hear
microphone working I'm very happy to be
here as you're mentioned my name is
Hannah I'm a PhD candidate in a section
of horticulture I am excited to share
some of my thoughts and results from
research focusing on how we as a
vegetable greens program can deploy some
consumer-driven strategies in the
development of we see Brassica varieties
and I still have quite a bit of I have
still several months before I defend and
quite a bit of synthesis to do before
this story kind of comes full circle but
regardless I hope that today creates a
nice opportunity for some discussion and
feedback on some of these strategies and
employing as Grist mentioned we are a
diversified vegetable breeding program
we work on many different crops we focus
on those cold crops like broccoli and
cabbage cauliflower but we also venture
into snap beans and dry beans which is
how I met Chris we work on small fruited
Tomatoes which we've had some recent
releases of but really a program has
recently is characterized by kind of a
shift to select seen for quality traits
and selecting for kind of consumer
forward traits so traits that are
important to the appearance like shape
and color but also important to quality
like flavor texture things like that
a recent focus has really been on
breeding different leafy Brassica types
so by that I mean kales and collards and
exploring diversity in those leafy
brassicas and despite my parents
skepticism that I should work on kale
when I started I was intrigued by grapes
diversity and his program and I wanted
to see what I could contribute to the
development of these leafy Brassica
types just to content contextual
economically contextualize kale and
collard these leafy brassicas fall
within a large plant family known as
graphic you see a is a huge plant family
with lots of different diversity a lot
of the important horticultural and
horticultural relevant agronomically
relevant crops actually come from a
single genus within this plan and within
this family the Brassica genus and I
won't go into too much detail here other
and to say that this Brassica are our
programs focus focuses on just one of
the species in this larger plant family
the Brassica oleracea and this Brassica
oleracea is characterized by a diversity
of more of the types like broccoli and
cabbage and cauliflower all of which can
be crossed and combined to create new
diversity so it's a lot of fun to work
with from a breeding perspective however
breeding these leafy Brassica types
you're dealing often with biennial types
where it takes one year to go from seed
to seed and breeding these leafy
Brassica types can be a slow and
intensive process Griff said I should
just make this a it is a slow and
intensive process but depends on your
attitude I guess needless to say this
time of year when the greenhouse making
crosses we're hoping by the summer we
can plant it out in the field so come
September we can make selections
evaluation dig those up so we can burn
alized them all to bring them back out
into the greenhouses next December
January and start making process again
so it gets to be a tight schedule when
we're breeding leafy brassicas when we
only get seed once a year but I was not
really deterred by this when I arrived
because in going to grifs field I saw
that he had already started collecting a
diverse germ plasm base and really I
walked into a pretty wonderful breeders
palette when we're thinking about
breeding for consumer quality and
consumer forward traits when ice before
I started Griff was already working with
collaborators to evaluate collars in the
southeast us he was breeding broccoli
and improving broccoli for the East
Coast
he had projects to improve pigmentation
and brassicas for the natural color
industry and then 2014 hit and a kale
craze came and so we started
incorporating different leaf shapes and
leaf types from more of the kale germ
plasm as well so I walked into a
breeders palette of different shapes and
sizes and colors that was just visually
very fun and what you can see here is on
the right is actually a pca of
commercially available leafy Brassica
varieties
and materials from our program
characterized by GPS markers and I don't
want to go into too much detail but
basically these light colors and yellow
orange and red represent either wild
progenitors or commercial hybrids or
open pollinated varieties available
commercially and you can contrast that
diversity with diversity from our
program which are in grey and purple and
these represent just a small subset from
a program and just a small subset from
what's commercially available but they
essentially demonstrate that our program
has genetic material that could
diversify the Brassica oleracea
landscape and marketplace which is
pretty exciting right so I walked into
that beautiful diversity of a program
and at the same time I started to dabble
a little bit in exploring food science
and I enrolled in a product development
course through the department of food
science and as I was in this class we
were often discussing how products often
go from idea and inception to a
prototype to testing and to eventual
release and as we were discussing the
food product development pipeline I
noticed there were a lot of parallels to
the plant product development pipeline
or the breeding pipeline as well both
have underlying themes of involving
multiple players of wheat plant breeders
are working with farmers and
distributors and processors often same
thing goes for food product developers
there's also the underlying themes that
these are kind of exploratory pipelines
where you might it might just not be a
linear line but you're kind of jumping
forward and back throughout the pipeline
and kind of receiving iterative
iterative feedback throughout both of
these pipelines but I did notice that in
plant breeding pipelines at least how
they were described in text and often
depicted was that they didn't mention
markets and users or consumers as often
as food product development pipelines
would that's not to say that that
discussion didn't happen or it didn't
exist it just wasn't totally apparent to
me and I didn't see their presence as
often and it was interesting because at
the same time I was seeing all the
servers in the field I was taking this
product development class I was also
kind of extending my knowledge in
and seeing influences that were
happening in the broader food system and
a lot of my influence was drawn from
some public plant breeding projects such
as the culinary breeding network out at
Oregon State the seed the kitchen
collaborative at UW Madison or the bread
lab out at Washington State and these
public projects sought to connect
players across the food system to
develop products or unique markets and
unique and diverse needs an exposure an
interest in these projects really kind
of opened my eyes to other trends I
guess across the food system so I've
seen trends and toured local food
through CSA's and farmers markets
I was also exploring methods of
participatory plant breeding that
involved many different players in the
development of varieties and ultimately
were also influencing how seed companies
were evaluating and releasing varieties
and these trends even got further up the
chain and so I thought I'd noting
noticing changes in dining and in
grocery retail and a meal delivery
services and my brain became a mess but
I thought it would be interesting too I
noticed how the consumer and had a
imperative role in how food was sourced
developed and consumed and that'll be
interesting to talk about and ask about
what a consumer-driven or a consumer
forward approach in our breeding program
might look like and whether it might be
feasible to implement now I'm certainly
not the first person to think about
consumer forward breeding arguably fruit
breeders have been thinking about this
for many many years
economic crops with high value processed
products like wheat and barley and
potatoes have been thinking about end
users for many years so I'm not the
first to think about this even plant
breeders and brassicas have worked on
consumer forward traits we can go back
to the late 70s early 80s when we
started to see some diversification in
the color of cauliflower appear on
markets we can go to the mid 80 plate
80s where Dutch
readers reading for lower glucosinolate
brussel sprouts to impart a less bitter
taste in brussel sprout varieties and
even more recently we can see the
release of kale let's from tozer seeds
in about 2012-2013 which is a cost of
Brussels sprouts and kale and
essentially introduced a completely
different novel morbo type to market so
I'm not the first to think about this
but the given the recent rise in
popularity of different kale types and
the fact that I was working in a
relatively new leafy Brassica breeding
program it led me to ask well what's
holding us back from developing new
types of leafy brassicas with different
tastes different appearance and
different novelty and what I was led to
was the fact that we had a void in our
breeding program we didn't have any
consumer insight in our breeding program
we didn't have information about
potential markets we didn't have
information about consumers in these
markets and their motivators or their
preferences so I was missing a lot of
information and consumers are constantly
changing their the way they interact
with products constantly changed and
these changes necessitate using tools
that are commonplace in the food
industry and product development to
obtain consumer insight some of these
there's a lot of overlap in the tools
that are used with some of these tools
include like marketing and market
research so thinking about concepts
testing message testing pricing web page
clicks etc research and development
changing of technologies are prophesying
sales being revenue or industry reports
and then finally the consumer product
testing which really tries to hit on how
consumers are interacting and perceiving
products and I thought well most of
these are way beyond my expertise or a
comfort zone I thought that the consumer
product testing component might be an
area where I could explore tools that we
as plant breeders could connect with
consumers so some of these tools include
sensory testing
consumer use studies focus groups
qualitative assessments etc and so these
were kind of the tools I had in mind of
using and as I was thinking about how we
apply them I came up with the big
questions and I thought that I could
using these tools and all the diversity
in our breeding programs begin to answer
a few things the first was Exploratorium
nature is their sensory variation in our
leafy Brassica germplasm if there's not
variation as a breeder for a trait we
don't have any ability to make
selections or make improvements or
release anything novel so we have to
know that there is variation there my
second question was plant breeders are
not food scientists and they're not
sensory analysis and now assists so how
do we think about doing sensory
conducting sensory analysis in
non-traditional setting that plant
breeders more commonly operate in
another big question that had in my mind
was in our breeding program we have a
huge amount of diversity and a large
number of lines that were often working
with so how do we handle these large
number of lines and consumer in the
consumer context and then finally how
good of a phenotype is consumer liking
when we're thinking about making
breeding decisions can we use consumer
liking to make impactful breeding
decisions so these four questions kind
of framed my dissertation and they're
gonna frame the rest of this talk and
hopefully we'll get through them all but
the first I want to talk about was what
I jumped into right away when I got here
was all right is there variation for
sensory traits in our program so knowing
this I set up a few objectives that I
thought would be useful in answering
this question and I was first just
characterize our breeding program for
sensory traits and consumer preferences
the second would be to determine whether
there were certain sensory traits that
we could strategically deploy or select
for in our breeding program as well
those are pretty clear objectives in my
mine there was only a couple problems
the first was that I was extremely
intimidated this was my field that we're
working in when I first arrived and if
this is what you're told you can work
with you don't really know where to
start so it's overwhelming to me in that
sense the second reason was overwhelming
was because I have no idea how to do
consumer product testing it was a
completely new field to me so I really
needed to step back and think about who
I could partner with to answer some of
these questions right so at that point I
got in touch with the Cornell sensory
center and I was very fortunate to start
forming some collaborations with Robin
Dano and Alina Selleck and Elena's here
today and I'm very glad because these
two house set up a foundation for most
of the rest of my research going forward
and in talking with them they really put
my mind at ease because they said all
right all that diversity that you
haven't filled in all those numbers that
you have those are actually assets when
we're looking to deploy new products
into the food industry so let's use them
let's explore them and then let's use
them so in talking with Alina we set up
kind of a strategic plan to evaluate all
these materials and we approach it from
two different perspectives we use a
qualitative product research assessment
and then we also use some quantitative
sensory analysis as well I'm going to
talk just a little bit about about those
but between these two processes we
really created a holistic picture of the
sensory landscape of leafy brassicas so
our first study was a qualitative
sensory analysis where we thought to
explore how consumers are interacting
with leafy brassicas and explore their
needs and wants without much
interference from us as researchers and
so using a series of qualitative
assessments kind of all combined into
one method known as a qualitative
multivariate analysis we were able to
assess kind of the consumer consumer
values and emotions associated with kill
purchasing and consumption
so to start off this study we assembled
a group of 14 different consumers who we
gave six different leave types of leafy
brassicas and we sent them home with
these different leaf types we said cook
them in your own kitchen prepare them
however you want but you have to keep
some really good notes on what you do so
we made them take journals and
photographs and document their
experiences with these products and
about two weeks later we brought them it
back in for an intense 3-hour focus
group we dissected all the kale emotions
you could imagine but in this focus
group is very dynamic discussion between
these participants who were well
informed and well versed in this product
set and we were able to perform some
product mapping we discussed the values
associated with purchase and consumption
and then most importantly we established
a foundation for understanding what
sensory attributes might be important to
differentiating these products in a
consumers mind so there's this
qualitative portion to this study and
then the following year we jumped into
the more quantitative sensory analysis
side of it where we thought to pick
apart whether those differences between
products that we talked about in the
focus group and what through a
qualitative assessment were in fact true
differences so we did a two-part study
using these quantitative measures the
first of which we trained a descriptive
panel to be able to identify and rate
the intensity of about 40 different
sensory attributes standing texture and
flavor and aroma and through those rate
identity through the identification and
rating of those attributes we're able to
differentiate the different leaf types
in our program according to different
sensory traits and then the second part
of this quantitative portion we asked
about a hundred different consumers to
come in and try different leaf types
from our program and rate how much they
liked or disliked these types and by oh
by combining these two pieces of
information we were able to understand
what consumer clusters prefer what types
and what are the underlying sensory
traits that are driving some of the
liking in these types as well okay feel
like I'm going a little fast so I just
want to encourage anyone to ask
questions if you have any along the way
but yeah because I'm still excited about
this even though this rap couple years
ago yeah great so um I mean out of both
is qualitative in this quantitative
portions we can definitively say that
there is in fact variation in Lethe
brassicas sensory attributes we found
out of those about 40 different
attributes that about 20 of them were
significantly different among the leaf
types the majority of which were coming
from textural attributes so we're
talking about chewy we're talking about
adhesive and fibrous things like that
that we're really differentiate our leaf
leaf genotypes this work was recently
published in the Journal of food science
so I encourage you to look into it more
but we've also coming out of it really
generated foundation for any other leafy
Brassica breeding program but there's
many but for anyone else interested in
evaluating quality in leafy brassicas to
have a lexicon to use and to understand
what traits they might first look for if
they want to start improving these types
right so there's most definitely a
difference in in visual qualities we did
not however ask the consumers in that
study to view whole leaves so when they
got or received a sample it was already
cut up so the ability to evaluate whole
leaf appearance was not so strong but I
have another project later where we do
evaluate appearance so I'll get to that
in just a little bit yeah so lots of
other things we could say directions we
could take this study I think I really
want to point out that all of this was
only performed using one preparation
method and that is rokkyo I mean
probably having eaten a lot of raw kale
lately maybe you have well I guess
that's technically raw but it's got
dressing on it if you ate a salad in the
back
but checking and validating these this
lexicon and this resource with other
alternative preparation methods would be
very important and then again
correlating those textural attributes
with actual plant traits is going to be
imperative if we want to breed for them
in our program as well so that kind of
wraps up that first question we have
variation good let's go let's move
forward let's figure out how we can
capitalize on that variation and I still
had three other lingering questions and
one of the biggest ones that I walked
away from this for study with was trying
to figure out how we as plant breeders
can conduct sensory analysis many
sensory techniques are difficult with
non processed products and they're not a
man who always sensory analysis methods
aren't always amenable to the
environments in which plant breeders
work like the field their conferences
and they can also be expensive so had
lots of questions about how we can also
explore sensory analysis and an on
standardized setting I suppose and I
approached this question from a couple
different perspectives and I certainly
wish I had more time to discuss this
project these two projects but I'm just
going to introduce them and let you know
I'm thinking about them the first was
really me asking the question well what
if we brought sensory evaluation to
those places in which consumers and food
are interacting I was seeing breeding
programs and groups performing sensory
tests at trade shows and conferences
things like that
and it's curious how well these
environments provide valid and useful
sensory information to a breeding
program so in September 2018 I partnered
with Gro NYC and green markets to
conduct sensory evaluation in three
different markets across New York City
and I also conducted those same sensory
evaluation tests in the Cornell sensory
center and this study allowed me to
understand how information collected at
the farmers markets might compare to
that information collected in a highly
controlled environment as well
and it allowed me to assess the
feasibility of a breeding program moving
out and going into these institution of
settings when they want to perform
sensory evaluation my second project
explore thought to address the the time
and the financial constraints of sensory
analysis in a breeding program so I
employed what's known as a rapid sensory
evaluation method called flash profiling
to quickly describe a set of collards
both in upstate and in western Kenya -
pretty different regions but by using
this method I was able to contrast
lexicons and preferences in those two
regions without having to train a
descriptive panel which can be costly
and time intensive as well now again as
I said it you wish I had more time to
talk about these because these were very
experiential and they helped me kind of
they were formative and that to help me
contextualise a lot of this research but
I realized running down this question
could put me into a rabbit hole of
trying to identify the perfect sensory
method applicable for every breeding
program and that's just not possible
so I had to step back but I did learn a
lot about how we need adaptable methods
that we where we can collect information
easily from participants that we more
commonly work with as plant breeders so
lots of directions to go there and I'm
going to skip forward though because I
know you're wondering are we ever going
to get to the last three questions and
we are because these are two really big
and important questions in my mind and
good news is I'm gonna try to tackle
them both in the same project and in
doing so I had to really think
creatively because they seemed like two
very different questions but in order to
answer them I needed to combine them so
with a little bit of creativity I
thought about the tools that I could use
to answer both of those questions and to
answer how we handle the large number of
lines and the diversity inherent with
our breeding programs I dug deep into
the plant breeding toolbox and some of
the methods that I had learned in plant
breeder
classes and decided to use what's known
as a dialogue mating design I'll talk
about that more in a little bit on the
consumer side can we use consumer liking
to evaluate breeding to make breeding
decisions I dug deep into the sensory
evaluation tools and decided to conduct
a consumer survey and it's really
through the combination these two tools
that I realized I was able to gauge
consumer perception of many different
leafy Brassica types and determine
whether certain parents and hybrids are
more liked by consumers as well let's
pick this apart because it's not making
a lot of sense now I'm sure but here is
that plant breeding tool that we have
the dial oh now the dial is the term for
a mating design that involves crossing
among many different diverse parental
lines mating designs are really common
to understand the inheritance of complex
genetic trait complex quantitative
traits but it's also used to estimate
the amount of genetic variance in a
population and it can also be used to
estimate whether there are parental
affects and whether certain parents and
a population more greatly affect a
phenotype so it has a lot of utility in
the plant breeding world these are not
question marks either should be excess
as in representing themselves because
what this diagram depicts is the actual
crossing scheme that I used so you can
see I have eight different inbred
parents on the axes here and these eight
different parents come from our breeding
program and represent essentially eight
different market classes of Leakey
brassicas we have a collared type we
have a curly kale Tuscan kale etc and
what I did with these eight inbred
parents is cross them in all possible
cross combinations so they're crossed
all to each other and in doing so
developed what I'm calling a hybrid
progeny set of 28 different hybrids
since yeah so coming out of this I
essentially have 36 different very
different diverse leafy Brassica types
that I can then put into a concern
consumer survey
I ended up creating an online consumer
preference survey by imaging all of the
36 leaves from the dialog and uploading
them to a Qualtrics or a survey online
survey format now by imaging these li
imaging these leaves
I'm yes only addressing one sensory
modality appearance there's a lot of
other things that are going to come into
play when we're talking about overall
liking of a product but I'm making the
concession for this study to just study
appearance right so all of these leaves
are now in the survey and when a
participant would click into the survey
they would be given a random subset of
seven leaves to look at from that dialog
design within each leaf they would be
asked two primary questions the first is
how much do you like this leaf on a
scale of one to nine how much do you
like or dislike this leaf type the
second question I asked was how familiar
are you with this leaf have you seen it
before it doesn't ring any bells and
that was just a one to five scale after
they viewed this seven leaf types we
asked a little bit of questions about
demographics and consumption patterns at
the end and then let them go on their
way and now I released a survey through
the Cornell sensory center and within a
week and a half at five hundred and
sixty seven participants in this study
which is pretty darn cool because they
saw just a subset of that SiC those six
types or sorry those 36 types that means
each leaf image was viewed approximately
a hundred and thirty-two times and we
had some good numbers to run some
differences some statistic done as well
coming out of this survey right on so
the main hypothesis in combining these
two tools is that expected market
classes like that iconic curly kale and
like Collard are going to exhibit a high
positive correlation with familiarity
these are the two most common on the
marketplace that we expect them to be
the most familiar but they all the the
other hypothesis is that these
established market classes will also
exhibit a high general combining ability
within the context of this dialo that is
these parents and all of their hybrid
progeny on average are going to be rated
higher for liking than other parents and
progeny in the dial oh those are my two
kind of hypothesis hypotheses moving
forward before I give away the big
reveal of what was like the best I want
to talk about that second question I
asked first and that is about
familiarity because immediately when we
got this data back we noticed that there
was a significant positive correlation
between familiarity and liking so you
can just see here as familiarity went up
liking also went up for these different
genotypes kind of make sense we like
what we know also kind of makes sense
that the most familiar was the most
prevalent market class type is iconic
curly kale the least familiar was this
Tuscan kale type we can talk about that
later
and it was hard for me to really assess
what was driving liking there weren't
many demographics that were popping up
as significantly affecting familiarity
other than the fact that people who ate
more leafy bracket brassicas tended to
rate Leaf types more familiar make sense
they eat more of them right but it's
very important to wait know this knowing
that it's important to wait familiarity
against liking because otherwise we as
plant breeders might be missing
opportunities to develop a release
varieties that people are not familiar
with but they might actually like and
with enough exposure might even adopt
into their regular routine so I put
together two different models that do
and do not incorporate familiarity and
what you can see here is a graph of
those two different models where we do
not have a molarity and we do have some
really arity and then a y equals x line
where you can see that the mean change
of incorporating familiarity affects
certain varieties more than others so we
saw a few different rank changes
depending on where they are in relation
to this line but in general we saw
trends in that that leaf type that was
most familiar and its progeny tended to
go down
and liking as we accounted for
familiarity and then that leaf type the
purple curly kid or the purple deep
fruitful kale that no one's really seen
before went up in like a little bit I
think get that there so there were some
rank changes but in general even after
we accounted from familiarity it didn't
necessarily affect the ends of our
distribution for liking that is those
that were most liked stayed the most
liked and those that were the least
liked stayed the least liked so with
that I present the most light in leaf
like pipes so on the top we have our top
five most liked leaves from this study
on the bottom we have the least liked
and just visually looking at this you
can start to see that there's some
trends up at the top we have Collard
types and though that curly green kale
type kind of shining through and then on
the bottom we actually have the two
different parental types the Tuscan kale
and a jagged leaf broccoli and then some
of their progeny in the least light so
just looking visually at these leaves
you can kind of see and think that oh
they're probably some parental affect to
liking going on here we can also look at
this from a couple other angles by
overlaying liking on to that original
dialog diagram so here those squares and
those leaves with darker orange behind
them were more liked than those with
lighter orange behind them and so you
can start to see some banding patterns
along the parental belong certain
parental pipes that are are more liked
or that are less liked another way to
visualize it is to actually use some GPS
markers on this dial offset and run a
structure analysis where the genotypes
are colored according to parental
representation and then they're ordered
according to overall liking so those
that are most likely up at the top and
those that are least liked are down at
the bottom and you can kind of see in
this graph too that those Collard
parents appear up at the top and those
from the Tuscan and the jagged leaf
parents appear at the bottom all right
so we visually assess this whole
parental affect thing but we want to see
some numbers so dug into the
quantitative Janette
portion of my limited background and
decided to assess these parental effects
using heritability and now heritability
is a measure that seeks to describe the
overall variance percentage of a
variance of a phenotype that's due just
to the genetic effects so you exclude
environmental you exclude the
participant effect and so how much of
the variance that we see and overall
liking is just due to genetics and this
descriptor can be viewed in a couple
different ways the first is known as
broad sense which accounts for all sorts
of all of the genetic effects and in our
case in the context of the study this
broad sense measures essentially our
ability to find crosses that are more
that tend to be more liked than others
it's very high we have 36 different
genotypes our ability to find one that
might be more liked is relatively high
the other measure of heritability
accounts for just the parental effect or
just the additive genetic variance and
trying to figure out how much of it how
much of our phenotype overall liking is
a result of additive variance and so
within our study this narrow-sense
heritability is really our ability to
select a parent one of those eight
parents in the dial oh that tend to
produce progeny that are more liked
humming since we're following them okay
so heritability of the can of worms and
a lot of plant breeding discussions and
I don't want to get too far into it but
if there's any plant breeders in the
room where a gawking at these numbers
these are very high for heritability
numbers we have to contextualize them in
this the context of this study we had
each leaf viewed 113 times essentially
that's like 113 replications of each
leaf so these heritability calculations
just by the nature of the equation are
bound to be high but if we think about
our ability to find crosses that one
participant tends to like more than
others but so using just a sample size
of n those heritability estimates go
down dramatically
and I guess at this point I really like
to thank Nick and Antonio for helping me
kind of think through some of these
descriptions and how to convey the
message message here but ultimately what
I want you to take away is that our
ability to use genetic and consumer
liking is small but it's not zero yeah
so with that I want to also address the
but why why are we seeing these genetic
effects there's got to be some
underlying reason or underlying plant
trait that's driving these so to address
this question
I started looking at just what those
participants who took the survey might
have seen so the images I went back to
each image and I extracted the percent
of each image that was occupied by a
leaf and termed that the images visual
volume and we can see here that as
visual volume increased liking also
increased so people like bigger things I
guess not quite sure but it's certainly
something to keep in mind in the
development of future surveys that may
be more than one photograph of leaf
types might be beneficial there other
thing I did with these images was
extract the most prominent colors from
each image so I extracted the four most
prominent colors from each genotype here
and I organized them just like that
structure platform most like the least
liked and I was really hoping to see
some really prominent color trends here
and I guess if you blur your eyes you
can kind of see that more green is at
the top and there's a little blue green
at the bottom but in general just
looking at this I can't make a lot of
generalizations about color driving like
you and at least in this study so
there's lots of other traits that we've
also looked at in this dial and I don't
have time to talk about it but we
phenotype these traits in the field last
summer as well so I have lots of
information on morphological attributes
like the degree of blistering and leaf
curl lamina width patio width etc and
and through partnership with Carl Femmes
Sam's at University of Tennessee we also
have some information on taste and
nutrition
coming down the RET down the road so we
have lupus in elite data and we'll have
carotenoid and anthocyanin data as well
and using all of these diverse plant
traits we can overlay consumer liking
and see if we see some trends there but
that is in the works down the road and
even after I get through this I'm still
not sure I'm going to have all the
answers as to why exactly we're seeing
these genetic effects but we're trying
so coming out of this project there are
many directions that I would improve and
think about revising namely I guess I
would think about streamlining this
dialogue he's very diverse parents in
this meeting design and as such there's
a lot of confounding factors so it's
difficult to parse apart whether color
or whether the leaf curl is affecting
overall liking more so thinking about
using something that's a little bit more
streamlined like it's these Tuscan kale
lines that are coming down the pipeline
in our program that Griff is holding
where they don't have different leaf
shapes and they're don't have different
sizes
you're only differentiated for color
might be something to probe in the
future and then on the consumer side I
realized that we only sent it out to
consumers in New York and so leafy
brassicas are consumed worldwide they're
not consumed at all in some places I
guess but it'd be interesting to
understand liking across a geographical
range I'm not going to get too far into
the rest but there's just a lot of
directions that we could take take this
take this study but important insights
that we walk away with from this large
study is that parental selection remains
important as we read new varieties I
think any plant breeder probably tell
you that but I guess I've confirmed it
in leafy brassicas consumer liking as a
phenotype has some genetic component
according to this study but we require a
large number of participants in order to
be able to see that signal and further
we need to continue to think about
creative approaches to answer these last
two questions that I had how do we deal
with a large number of lines and how do
we gauge consumer liking and how do we
integrate different sensor
besides just appearance so those
creative approaches not that I've run
dry of creativity but require multi
disciplinary partners and so a tenant of
our program has really been to reach out
to diverse groups whether they're an
industry or the private or the public
sector as well because these groups can
kind of push you in what you think trade
priorities should be and open up your
mop your open up opportunities to new
markets so just next week we're actually
meeting with Digg to discuss breeding
for softer stems for their restaurant
use and that the same visit we're going
to Bowery farms to discuss what a
breeding program for vertical
agriculture might look like and so trade
priorities exist far beyond just
consumer liking and it's important to
talk across the food system to
understand what other trade priorities
should exist and this is not to
overwhelm you at all but these are just
graphs of the people I've worked with
along the way I wish I had other images
of actual people but these are the
demographics of individuals who
participated in three out of my four
studies and I really do think that
there's value in some of this work
because the minute we involve consumers
and end users and the evaluation of some
of our reading materials we also engage
in outreach and education so in total
after filtering 1,848 people contributed
to my dissertation directly which is
pretty darn cool I feel like a plant
breeder being like I worked with 30
million snips I worked with 1,848 people
that's pretty cool pretty cool to me now
are all 1840 if people are going to
adopt our new kale varieties probably
not but we've at least captured their
voice in evaluating that and finally I
just want to hint it some other things
that are coming out of our product
pipeline we are trying to cater to those
1,848 people
through many different ways we're
continuing to breed for the market
standards the iconic curly kale so on
the left here you see some trials with
high mowing seeds where we're selecting
for tighter curl and a little bit longer
leaf type for those markets in the
middle here you see an incremental
product development to essentially make
kale accessible so this Tuscan kale type
was a least liked in our program but
what happens when we start to change the
color does that change the perception
and does that make it more approachable
by people who do not traditional
traditionally consumed kale we'll see
but it's kind of like thinking about you
wouldn't jump into eating the flamin hot
they'll pickle potato chip before you
try a regular potato chip first so let's
let's see how we can ease them into the
flamin hot
Tuscan kale right and then last I want
to say we're also hedging our bets with
novelty as well we are in the final
stages of testing this variety which is
spotted to be called daydreamer through
Johnny seeds but it really combines some
of those main things I saw in this last
survey where we have that little bit of
familiar leaf curl we have a bright
green color and then we have this
unfamiliar but liked red midrib so we'll
see how this does it's going to be
exciting over the next few years to see
some of these come to marketplace
because we're getting very close with
them and to see what happens when they
become subject to the food system and
all of its ins and outs and critiques so
I'm very excited and happy to be part of
of the development of some of these
types with that I want to wrap up with
just so many thank yous I feel very
fortunate to have a committee that is
supportive and understanding Griff and
Steve and Olga I'm very appreciative my
work at a sensory Center as I said
establish my foundation for a lot of
this work so thank you Alena thank you
Robin and then all of the Griffith lab
members they've been such a support in
such a humorous group to work with I'm
glad to have them on my side and then
brain-busters along the ways
and Nick and Lynn Carl Charles super
glad to have you all around and then all
the folks who helped with the production
inside whether it's in the greenhouse or
the field I'm very very grateful see
that and then finally my family and
friends who are still with me in my 37th
year of grad school no I'm not 37 so I
don't know how many more questions so
with the dislike of the Tuscan kale do
you think it might be related to the
fact that the leaves are so much smaller
and that the consumer doesn't think
you're getting value if you're buying
the same amount and the second you
should be graph the different ruthless
enolates is there any correlation
glucosinolates and visual I can see for
anthocyanins and carotenoids but any
first question for those who didn't hear
dan is asking about whether the
perceived value of Tuscan kale was less
because it didn't occupy as much it
wasn't as large had thinner leaves and
that's why I really calculated the
visual volume because that was something
I saw I was like okay yeah I used three
leaves in each image but the Tuscan kale
just doesn't occupy as much space or
people thinking they're not getting the
same yield or they're not getting the
same value and that would require much
deeper questions to answer but it's
certainly something that I'm aware of
and why I think we should take multiple
images of each leaf from different
angles to see if it's a true artifact of
the leaf or if it's artifact of the
image yeah and then the second question
was with regard to whether there's a
correlation between appearance and
glucosinolates and that's a very hard
draw yeah totally glucosinolates our
taste in parting compounds that you
probably don't see right off the bat and
so I don't know but I would love in
future surveys to actually probe probe
nutritional perceived nutritional calm
content like how much how nutritious do
you think this leash is because that
might be affecting overall liking as
well by just looking at this PCA that I
put together of glucosinolates over and
the genotypes interesting to note that
most of those likes genotypes are
actually highest in glucose in elites as
well and then the Tuscan types are on
the opposite side so can we see a
nutrition probably not but there's other
questions we can ask for sure yeah
Geneva I know you're there hopefully do
you have any questions
I have a question can you hear me yes I
can okay this is great great seminar but
my question is what do you think is the
right balance between directly
incorporating consumer feedback into the
breeding process in terms of actually
making selections versus maybe the more
traditional approach where the breeder
you know it has in his or her mind what
he or she thinks the market demands and
just individually making selections
thinking about what consumers eventually
want being really driven by one person's
ideas right right those are those are
two kind of polar opposites it's a right
oh is that about whether we use a model
that is completely focused on using
consumer liking as where the market goes
and where our selection goes or relying
on the breeder to determine where the
market goes and I guess this is this is
opinion I view that the idea that one
person's opinion is right is wrong I
there's no way that a single person can
capture information across a food system
and be able to synthesize all of it and
so a large driver for me in this
research was that at least we're talking
to other people and integrating their
their feedback and you can choose
whether to incorporate that into your
breeding decisions through something
like a weighted selection where you
incorporate consumer liking but to a
small degree in your overall selection
scheme
so there's yeah the balance between
those is really hard and I'm not sure
I've answered your question exactly
because I don't have it figured out
because again it depends on breeding
program and and a breeders Drive to to
connect and understand players across
the food system so I hope that helps
okay
back did you partition any of your
survey results data and see different
patterns and consumer preference and of
themselves for example are some
consumers more novelty seeking and some
are more traditional and then the second
question what are those two things
you're holding and why okay
the first question is a gas was with
regard to whether I partitioned out kind
of the demographics of consumers and
whether there were underlying behavioral
patterns to the consumers in this study
that might be driving their familiarity
or their liking and I did not ask what
is a very important question and that is
re do you have variety seeking behavior
because there are some people who know
what they know and that's all they want
and that is totally fine but there are
also other people who very much seek out
new ideas new things new products and
want to try the newest and latest and
those are two different very - very
different consumer groups and so it's
important to ask these variety seeking
behavior questions in future surveys I
definitely would love to I'd also love
to pick apart the demographics a bit
further because it'd be interesting to
contrast those people in that large
survey who consumed leafy brassicas
consistently and reported eating kale
most commonly to those people who don't
eat leafy brassicas as much and eat kale
and eat kale when when they do
eally frescas eat kale because those are
also very different questions yeah oh
and this is my happiest moment in Ithaca
next to get married I guess I am
the 2016 international rutabaga curling
champion and so this is me holding the
winning rutabaga and my for winning that
curling championship and I'm getting
time but I'd love to talk to you after
anyway one more question sure okay sorry
one more question yeah I was a question
so much as a comment on
you as a question sir but I wonder too
if how it people perceive adhesive
preparation because look it's just
really tough to prepare and cut the stem
off or something so you know say I don't
really like want to deal with that
right right right like would would you
envision incorporating this into part of
your routine or do you view it as too
much of a barrier to work within the
kitchen is a super great question
absolutely and definitely something we
can do and this is always what we
struggle with when we're talking about
consumer research because you want to
ask so many questions but they don't
they don't they don't want to spend that
much time you have about five seven
minutes maximum to capture consumer
information and so you have to really be
onion in what questions you're asking
but I have many more so thank you for
coming today y'all say fair Jackson
sorry this has been a production of
Cornell University on the web at cornell
edu